it's Wednesday the 10th of May I'm Dan
and I'm often asked how I ended up here
well instead of studying in year 12 I
perfected this oh god what have I done
first up if you've got an idea for a
radical Xbox one controller now might be
the time to claim it as Microsoft might
give you some sweet digital currency in
the latest marketing campaign that gets
consumers to do free work for a
multi-million dollar corporation if you
design an Xbox one controller using the
Xbox design lab program and it becomes
popular then you might earn some sweet
digital currency Laurence Thompson chief
creative officer at Xbox ad agency
McCann London said when you design a
controller on the platform
beyond owning it the unique design
actually becomes yours yours to name and
yours to promote for the first time you
can earn from it will even give you all
the marketing tools so you can push it
yourself be quick though it's only the
first person to claim ownership of a
particular design is eligible to earn
rewards from it according to the
original marketing material for the Xbox
design lab there's 8 million
combinations so you better be quick the
Xbox design lab is currently only
available in the US and Canada though
Microsoft has plans to roll it out in
other regions later this year the
bodacious nice lighting third-person
shooter from Platinum Games vanquish is
now available on PC after teasing it
repeatedly via Twitter Seger today
announced that vanquish is coming to
steam on May 25 now for all those
features PC players care about vanquish
PC will feature unlocked framerate
unlocked HD resolutions and extensive
graphics options there's also a deluxe
edition that comes with a soundtrack
sample of five songs avatars a digital
art book and desktop wallpapers if you
already bought Bayonetta on PC after its
April release or pick it up before May
25 you'll get a 25% discount on vanquish
when it's released
you should totally grab both because
they are wicked fun Seeger also teased
more announcements to come saying
there's more to come from Seger in this
space so stay tuned for further
announcements we'll be keeping you up to
date on whatever Seeger announces next
so be sure to subscribe sorry about how
I say Sega Sega saga finally an update
for Mass Effect Andromeda has been
released along with news that the series
may be on hiatus first the update patch
1.06 makes changes to a wide range of
areas though the patch notes don't tell
us exactly what's changed cinematic
scenes have seen various improvements
particularly in the opening hours of the
conversation options should no longer be
grayed out when there's still new
dialogue options for you to hear chest
armor now has level requirements and
overall performance and stability has
been improved if you picked up the
deluxe or Super Deluxe Edition you'll
receive some free stuff in the form of
two Nomad skins a casual Pathfinder
outfit and an exclusive pack for
multiplayer that offers high odds of
getting an ultra rare item you can check
out the full list of patch notes over on
GameSpot in other Mass Effect news the
series is reportedly on hiatus
according to Kotaku additionally changes
are reportedly being made to the
direction of Bioware Montreal this all
comes just a day after EA voice support
for both the franchise and developer
during a conference call with investors
apparently Deb's from Bioware Montreal
have been moved to EA motive which is
contributing to the upcoming Star Wars
Battlefront 2 while the remainder of the
studio will continue working on
Andromeda multiplayer content or shift
to new Bioware IP
unfortunately that new IP has been
pushed back until at least April 2018
I'm hoping for something cyberpunk ea
clarified with GameSpot there hasn't
been any downsizing at Bioware Montreal
and that quote there will be much more
to come from Bioware in the years ahead
that's GameSpot news for today enjoy the
rest of your day or the full day that
may be ahead of you I've been dan and I
will see you all tomorrow